in this project we'll be exploring
fixing gaps between levels of detail
a problem that occurs whenever you put a
high and low resolution mesh side by
side
we fixed a bunch of crap in the last
video we used logarithmic depth buffers
to fix the zed fighting problems
and took a run at the precision problems
plaguing the texturing
that got us pretty far we can zoom in
and out and move around at ground level
and things mostly look fine except for
these
we gotta fix these slivers and gaps that
appear everywhere
this is the last piece of technical dead
hanging over our heads before we can
move on to something a bit more
interesting
and what's happening isn't too difficult
to understand
if this is our noise function let's draw
some sort of bumpy noise function below
it's continuous and if we had infinite
resolution represent this
there'd be no problems but we're fitting
quads over top
so if i draw a big quad over top of this
notice how that valley in the middle
doesn't get a vertex
but if i draw a second higher resolution
quad
that does catch the valley forming a gap
between it
and the lower resolution version how do
we fix this
there's a few ways the first potential
solution to this problem is as follows
say you've got your landscape here let's
just draw it out a bit
and these are the gaps in your mesh an
easy way to fix this
is to simply fill in these gaps by
adding another layer of vertices around
the edge of the terrain
effectively creating a skirt around
everything the upside to this approach
is that it's super duper easy
really just involves adding an extra
layer of vertices around the edge and
dropping them down
but the downside is that while easy you
may notice
inconsistencies in the terrain if you
were to say
look on the side at two chunks of
terrain instead of the smooth change
you'd expect from lower to higher
resolution
you'll see this abrupt cliff that leads
us to another potential solution
instead of skirts we could instead
stitch
the chunks together by moving the
vertices in the higher resolution chunk
to match the lower resolution one
there's a couple downsides
the first being that this adds a bit of
complexity since
each chunk now needs to know what
resolution its neighbor is
getting the neighbors isn't easy since
we're looking at a spherified cube
not just a bunch of quads another
problem is
there may be potential lighting problems
just fixing the mesh isn't enough
because normals are often generated from
the mesh topology itself
let's get coding first thing this code
is one
gross monolithic function and we're
about at the edge of what i can tolerate
so i'm just doing a quick cleanup pass
first separating things out into
functions before we move on
the code for the skirt itself is dead
easy we're just going to go into the
mesh generation code and add an extra
layer of vertices around the edge
you generate the normals off of that
which should smooth them out between
chunks
and then you need to do a pass where you
pull these vertices down
effectively creating a skirt and there
we go skirt enabled
notice all those little gaps in the
world are gone now can't see through it
anymore
if we freeze the terrain camera though
we can move around without the terrain
updating
what we see is that the lighting between
the chunks isn't too bad
especially if they're higher resolution
but you'll end up with stuff like this
where the lighting changes abruptly if
we jack up the height
and disable textures and just visualize
lighting directly
it's a lot easier to see the problem see
here where there's visible lighting
seams
performing mesh surgery so the skirts
got us pretty far
and you might even decide to stop there
i'm continuing on and hopefully fixing
the problem once and for all
now the problem is is that we've got
these chunks of different resolutions
sitting side by side
and we're going to need to go through
the mesh and perform a little surgery
moving vertices around so the edges
match
but we need the neighbor's resolution
but we're on a sphere
which complicates neighbor finding so
there's some hurdles
if you have a quadtree node and you want
to know what its neighbors are
on paper this is really easy it's just
all the nodes that are touching the one
that you're interested in
but in actual practice it's a tiny bit
more complicated
each node has four children so getting
two neighbors is trivial
they're just siblings but two aren't
they may share a common parent which
makes things a bit easier
or not and that common parent may be
further up the tree
in which case is not directly clear how
to get them
but an interesting observation is if
you've already figured out the neighbors
for the parent
then for each child looking for its own
neighbors it's a simple matter of
looking at the children of the parent's
neighbor
so that means to build neighbor
information efficiently we need to
process the quad tree
level by level filling out neighbor info
or in other words breadth first search
this doesn't quite hold up if you're on
a spherified cube at the edges
since you're looking at another side
with different orientations
but there you can fall back to looking
for closest child of the neighbor
instead
once we know the neighbors the way that
we can fix this is by iterating the edge
vertices
what you do is use that neighbor
information to calculate a stride
notice how i've calculated this stride
which is basically how many times bigger
the lower resolution mesh is and we'll
use that to skip vertices
in effect we're simulating the low
resolution on the high resolution mesh
by forcing the vertices to linearly
interpolate instead of more directly
representing the noise function
and there we go once this is enabled on
the train we can wander around
and i don't see any gaps so this is
doing pretty good
i've seen people kind of declare victory
here because this is already a huge win
and realistically from this vantage
point it's hard to see any problems
but there are still problems let's fix
the terrain camera in place and wander
around
now this might be just me being picky
but look at those weird lines
let's zoom in a bit you see those those
are lighting discontinuities
and they're caused by the fact that the
normals on the edges between chunks
don't match up exactly
let's try to fix this now the problem
here is that when you generate the
normals
those largely depend on the mesh's
topology meaning normals are usually
generated by combining phase normals in
some way
so let's say that i have two triangles
and will visualize this from the side
so these are the face normals the pur
vertex normals would look more like this
see how this top one here is kind of a
mix between the two
now imagine that the underlying noise
function looks more like this
so then if on the right i replace that
low resolution chunk with a higher
resolution one
let's just draw an extrovert once we
start combining these face normals into
per vertex normals
they're not going to be the same as the
first example how can we solve this
well what i figured is what if instead
of trying to use these mesh normals on
the edges
we use an analytical normal instead in
other words
we calculate it directly from the
underlying noise function
i can draw a few of these for reference
but that way
it'll be the same no matter which chunk
you're computing it for
the analytical normal is the true normal
and while it is possible to calculate
the analytical
derivative directly i'm going to be
using the central differences method
because i want to try and fiddle with
the delta to match the existing normals
at least hopefully so in code here we're
adding this function called compute
normal
central difference and it'll use a
little first year calculus to compute
the approximation of the derivative
using the essential differences method
and we're going to pass in a step size
that's relative to the max of the size
of the current node
and the neighbor sharing that edge and
here we go
this all kind of works now i'm not going
to lie this was a bit harder than i
expected it to be mostly because of
these small nitpicky problems that i
decided to dive into
my solution isn't perfect i'm not
pretending it is
but it seems to work and maybe someone
in the comments will have a better idea
and i'll revisit this and take another
pass but it's pretty serviceable as is
remember to patreon it up also like and
subscribe as always
if i remember the code will be up on
github so go check it out
let me know what you think until next
time cheers